[Music]
I’m here in India in Mumbai, what used to
be called Bombay, and behind me is the gateway
to India, the entrance to the continent. I’ve
come here to give lectures at the Asian Science
Camp and at the University and to talk to
Indian chemists and scientists and find out
about Indian science.
[Music]
It’s our first morning here in India and
we’re just going downstairs to meet Dr Gopperland,
who’s organising our visit, and then to speak
to the editor of the journal Chemical Weekly.
So I’m really quite excited. So my interview
I think went quite well, perhaps I talked
a bit much. But now we’re off to lunch, we’re
already late, to meet some people from the
chemical industry here in India and also a
really famous chemical engineer: the father
of chemical engineering in India.
[Music]
So we’re here in New Mumbai at the opening
of the Asian Science Camp 2010. And some of
the important scientists are going to make
speeches before the real lectures and exciting
part begins.
[Singing]
I’ve come here because I like talking to
young people; I knew the organisers and it
seemed a really good opportunity to meet some
of the brighter students in chemistry from
right across the world. I think an electric
power cut quite exciting. I’m hoping for
several things: first of all that my audiences
should enjoy themselves; they should understand
what I’m saying; I’m hoping that I’ll meet
some new people and perhaps set up some new
partnerships and collaborations.
[Music]
I’m here preparing for a talk ‘From Test
Tube to YouTube’. It’s not really a lecture
it’s what’s called a camp. I’m going to
try to get the students to talk to you and
see whether we can make a YouTube video during
a lecture.
Okay if you can’t hear me at any time wave.
You as a group are an exception, you’re people
who really like science.
Which of the explosion do you find most beautiful
and most exciting?
Hi Professor my question is this…
If you could be any element which would you
be and why?
[Music]
We’re in the Indian National NMR facility
Nuclear Magnetic Resonance and they’ve got
some terrific machines here. Honoured guests,
ladies and gentlemen I’m delighted to be
here. We’re at the Asian Science Camp and
one of the speakers is Professor Richard Ernst,
the Nobel Prize winner, and it is a great
opportunity for me and Brady to talk to him.
I mean initially there was some excitement,
people get used to it and they recognise that
I’m just a normal person.
So I’m just getting ready for my big lecture
to all the students and the room is set out
in rather a strange way.
Can you all hear me?... I don’t know how
many of you know what is a forklift truck?...
And the NH groups of this growing in… And
it turned out I had been wearing my wife’s
trousers!... As you go on in life you will
find that there isn’t just one person that
helps you but lots of people that help you…
First of all for the physicist I have a souvenir
from our university, for the chemist I would
like to give him my tie.